تنظم جمعيات مدنيه بمشاركه برلمانيه
ونشطاء وسياسيين وقفه تضامنيه مع الشعب
الفلسطيني في ساحه الاراده المقابله لمقر
البرلمان ومعنا من العاصمه بين الكويت
مدير مكتب الجزيره سعد السعيدي سعد اهلا
بك ما الذي يحدث اذا في ساحه الاراده حيث
انت
نعم سفيان سفيان استمرار
متواليه الدم التي يذهب دائما ضحيتها
الاطفال والنساء والشيوخ في فلسطين هي
التي جابت هؤلاء العشرات هنا لتنظيم هذه
التضامن ولتنظيم هذا التجمع الذي يراد منه
ايصال رساله رساله شفافه حقيقه كما يقول
هنا كل من تحدثنا معهم قبل هذه المداخله
بانهم يريدون ايصال رساله شفافه وواضحه لا
ضبابيه فيها شفافه يراد ان يقراها ويسمعها
ويشاهدها الجميع هنا بان الكويت عبر
موقفها الشعبي الان هي تتضامن مع ما حدث
تحديدا مع جنين في الايام الاخيره ومع
فلسطين بشكل عام وقضايا فلسطين بشكل كامل
هنا ايضا نرى حقيقه
تحولت هذه البقعه وهذه الساحه المحببه
لنفوس الكويتين تحولت وكانها قطعه من قطع
فلسطين هذه البقعه الصغيره حملت فيها هنا
صور للشهداء وصور للاسرى كما هما هون على
يساري واعلام فلسطين والصيحات ورفعت ايضا
ورفعت ايضا الكوفيه كوفيه النضال
والمقاومه ورمز السلطه او رمز فلسطين هنا
على الاعناق الكويتين هنا رجالا ونساء
حقيقه اشاهدون على يمين عائلات كثيره مع
مع اولادها وتحضر هنا وايضا هنا حضور
يتفاعل كثير الحقيقه مع هذه مع قضيه
فلسطين لا ينفصل حقيقه سفيان الموقف
الرسمي عن الموقف الشعبي نريد ان نستمع
الى هذه الصيحه فقط هذا الكتاب بشكل سريع
ثم نعود فقط
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
سفيان بالفعل هذه الهتافات المستمره دائما
والتي تؤيد دائما هذه القضيه الفلسطينيه
كنت اقول بان هذا الموقف الشعبي موقف اصيل
حقيقه او متاصل سبق هذا الموقف حقيقه ايضا
الموقف الشعبي ايضا بيانات لجمعيات مدنيه
30 جمعيه مدنيه هنا في الكويت ايضا كانت
تطالب وطالبت ايضا ان يتكامل الموقف
الرسمي البرلماني وكذلك الحكومي في ان يتم
هناك رفض تام للتطبيع وحمايه الشعب
الفلسطيني كان هناك بيان ايضا لوزاره
الخارجيه الكويتيه وهو البيان الرسمي
للدوله ويبين موقف الدوله الذي لا ينفصل
اذا هنا نتحدث عن موقف شعبي ورسمي لا
ينفصلان هنا في الكويت بتاييد تام للقضيه
الفلسطينيه وخصوصا في كل كلمه كانت لامير
الكويت سابقا قالها الرئيس السلطان
الفلسطينيه بان الكويت مع فلسطين في
السراء والضراء اذا تستمر هذه التجمعات
هناك حراك كبير حقيقه هنا وانزعاج وغضب
حقيقه لما يجري من فلسطين وتتضامن مع
القضيه الفلسطينيه بكل الملابسات التي
تحدث هناك ورفض للانتهاكات المستمره من
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]